♪♪
Detective Parsa:
There are no secrets in
the city of New York.
Detective Parsa:
There’s cameras everywhere,
phone records, parking tickets.
Detective Parsa:
Someone saw something,
heard something.
(Gun shot)
Detective Parsa:
The city always knows.
Sam got shot in Central Park.
Help!
♪♪
Charlie:
We’re like basically
best friends.
♪♪
Detective Parsa:
We’re going to find
who did this to her.
When we figure out who the
connection to Samantha is, we
figure out who shot her.
♪♪
Regan:
Two police detectives were here.
Where were you on July 4th?
♪♪
William:
I don’t know how,
I don’t know why,
but this girl is
connected to us.
♪♪
Charlie:
You guys know Sam?
You might know why she
left me and got shot?
♪♪
Nicky:
Sam was one of us.
(Camera click)
Whatever Sam knew,
I want to know too.
♪♪
Man:
She left me clues.
She was onto something.
William:
I think I’m the only one
that can figure this out.
Detective Parsa:
We gotta learn more
about these people.
♪♪
Detective McFadden:
Money for generations.
They’re hiding something.
♪♪
Nicky:
When we started this revolution,
we knew it would have a cost.
♪♪
Please!
Man:
You’re not the only
one with secrets.
♪♪